in just four years scientists have
detected over a thousand exoplanets just
from their shadows
but Kepler has a problem it can't tell
if the shadow is made by a giant gassy
planet hostile to life or a potentially
habitable earth-like planet
what we're measuring when a when a
planet passes in front of its host star
is what is the area of the planet
relative to the area of the star that
it's passing in front of it's a it's a
ratio basically but you better size
planets crossing giant stars full Kepler
because they block the same fraction of
light as earth sized planets crossing
smaller stars to prove a planet is earth
sized you first need to measure the size
of its star using the world's biggest
telescopes but that's time-consuming
expensive and it creates a huge
exoplanet backlog but astronomer Kavon
Stassen has come up with an ingenious
shortcut by turning the raw Kepler data
into sound what the Kepler telescope
directly measures and the data that we
use is the small changes in brightness
that a star produces due to the
flickering arising from the boiling and
roiling motions of gas at its surface
what we can do then is take that light
flickering data and transform it in a
sound studio for example into audio
frequencies and so then we can represent
with sound what we're actually detecting
with light
the bigger the star the more its surface
boils with activity making big stars
flicker more powerfully converted to
sound this boiling becomes a deafening
hiss well let's listen to some stars
okay can we hear the red giant star
please bring up the volume here this is
a very large star very low density and
so that large amount of hiss is the
result of vigorous boiling and churning
at the surface of this large red giant
star can we get the dwarf star please
on smaller stars sunspots dominate the
sound profile creating a low-frequency
drone actually sounds like a series of
clicks curve but below the clicks lies
the faint hiss Kavon needs to size the
star underneath it at a very low level
is a little bit of hiss
that little bit of is actually the light
flickering that we're interested in by
accurately measuring the level of this
background hiss Kavon can work out the
size of the star in this case it's
around the same size as our star the Sun
cave-ins work could be the breakthrough
exoplanet hunters have been hoping for
it's cheap the results are practically
instantaneous and once you know the size
of the star figuring out the size of the
planets casting shadows over it is
child's play it it feels like a very
privileged time to be a scientist to be
an astronomer working in this area and
contributing to the hunt for the next
earth here we are actually discovering
these worlds by the hundreds and now on
the cusp of being able to identify the
next earth